brazil's health care system is on the
verge of collapse according to its own
managers
many clinics are already too overwhelmed
by coronavirus cases to take in
any new patients more than 53 000
people have contracted covet 19 in
brazil
there are fears it could become one of
the world's pandemic hot spots
president jr bolsonaro still maintains
it's a relatively minor disease
bolsonaro is also facing a fresh blow to
his political authority his justice
minister has resigned accusing him
of meddling with the police
noisy protests rang out across brazil on
friday
drowning out the president's televised
address to the nation
jair bolsonaro defended his sacking of
the federal police chief
amid accusations that he was trying to
interfere in the country's justice
system
i don't have to ask for authorization
from anyone to change any official
or anyone else but both scenarios still
provided no reason
for the dismissal which had prompted the
resignation of brazil's popular justice
minister
on live tv
unfortunately i have no way to continue
with the commitment
that i assumed without being able to
preserve the autonomy
of the federal police to carry out their
work
sergio monroe's departure was a body
blow to a president
already under fire over his handling of
the coronavirus crisis
bolsonaro has repeatedly described coved
19
as a little flu but now hundreds of
victims are being buried in mass graves
state governors have brought in social
distancing measures
dismissed by bolsonaro as poison
officials are warning that hospitals are
on the brink of collapse
and the man at the top faces public
anger
growing louder by the day
now for more on this let's bring in
journalist michael fox from
florianapolis
michael brazil's former justice minister
sergio moro he was a popular politician
famed for fighting corruption
we heard him speak there in our report
he was a bit vague there
about his motives why did he resign
well it's still not very clear the i
mean
we know why he resigned he resigned
because bolsonaro fired police chief
marisol
now that was also mentioned in your
report now the intricacies of exactly
how
important was this or why that's what we
don't know
um he mentioned numerous times political
interference political interference from
the bolsonaro government
uh trying to take out the the federal
police chief
uh he also in several of his of his of
his talks and several of his points
he kind of alluded to to a series of
crimes that the bolsonaro government
may have been committing that bolsonaro
himself may have been committing uh
including
asking for updates on intelligence and
federal police investigations this would
be like
asking for updates from the fbi about uh
investigations that
are are confidential and the president
really doesn't have access to
and of course the idea of being able to
take out
this uh the federal police chief the
idea is that these are kind of separate
entities that bolsonaro
should not be meddling with um and there
but there's
there's a lot behind the scenes that we
don't know many people are mentioning
it could also be impacting uh or have to
do with bolsonaro's own sons now
all three of them are under they're all
politicians all three of them are under
investigation and some of them say very
serious investigations the intercept
just came out
with a bit of a bombshell this morning
about his son flavio
who's a former uh assembly
representative from rio de janeiro and
that he may have been involved
in kickbacks uh to build um public to
build housing for
paramilitaries in rio de janeiro and
money finance and whatnot so
there's a lot of issues here that we
just don't know yet
well michael his departure comes only a
week after the president sacked the
popular health minister
so this is another serious bill for
bolsonaro is he is he losing support in
the public
so you have to remember that even as of
a couple weeks ago
the health minister had roughly doubled
the support that bolsonaro has
uh he was up around in in the mid 60s in
terms of percentage and bolsonaro's
around
30 35 36 37. now remember also that
boston
is very similar to donald trump he has
his roughly third of the country
these are his supporters he's never had
more than that really uh and he knows
that he's able to
do things with that just like donald
trump he's able to manage the country
because these are his people
so the more drastic he is the more
bombastic oftentimes that kind of
uh gets his supporters even more on
board and that's what we're seeing
particularly with bolsonaro
breaking quarantines getting to the
protests supporting these protesters
saying that for instance the crow
dividers isn't that big of a deal or
that 70
of the country has to get sick before
this whole thing is over these are
things that he's doing to actually
soar up his support within his
supporters or out at the same time the
rest of the country is extremely nervous
about this
this crisis that just keeps the growth
michael fox there thank you very much
you